naïm orphelins et gunther marins
hollandais les deux personnages
principaux de benjamin flao l'artiste
fait de la bande dessinée inspirée de
souvenirs de voyage c'est un livre que
j'ai fait à partir de d'un voyage que
j'avais fait mais plusieurs voyages que
j'avais fait en afrique de l'est qui au
départ était sous forme de le matériau
que j'avais c'était c'était plutôt des
carnets de voyage des carnets et dessins
et puis des petites notes et que j'ai
transformée en
que j'ai transformée en
récit en fiction et finalement ça a
donné un diptyque avec tous les
ingrédients que j'ai pu piocher pour ces
voyageurs
[Musique]
l'afrique est la mer pour ce nantais de
naissance le grand bleu est une source
d'inspiration
parce que
d'une frappe en audience et dans sept
pays d'afrique c'est que il ya des
choses qui sont restés immuables
en tout cas des choses qui existaient
encore chez nous il ya cent ans qui ont
disparu qui ont cours trouvent dans les
musées et chez eux c'est encore bien
vivant on sait pas vraiment c'est pas
vraiment un garage s'est pas vraiment
mais un peu de bazar
il ya des choses qu'on voit pas trop
bien voilà mes rêves sont un peu fait de
deux ça benjamin flao dessine depuis
l'enfance aux histoires vraies se mêlent
les rêves et une vie à double facette
moi j'ai un peu de devis stallergènes
vie qui se passe à l'extérieur où par
exemple qui me
fait voyager qui me permet d'aller
promener donc en afrique par exemple
puis une vie intérieure qui par exemple
le maire rêve
alors là je parle de l'aspect graphique
surtout parce qu'il s'agit de l'expo de
dessin
[Musique]
voyageur au long cours il placard de ses
dessins sur des murs de temps d'une
exposition
avant de repartir vers de nouveaux rêves
[Musique]